cardi be arrested after an alleged
altercation at a strip club yeah got it
spent some money moves the NYPD confirms
to ET that the bodek yellow wrapper
whose real name is Belle Callas al
Mann's are turned herself into police on
Monday as part of an investigation into
an assault complaint stemming from an
incident on August 29th
authorities tell et the 25 year old got
in a fight at angels gentlemen's club in
New York where she allegedly threw a
chair at an unattended target cardi was
charged with two misdemeanors assault
and reckless endangerment and is set to
appear in court in coming weeks et has
learned she will not face jail time but
will pay a fine sometimes it gets a
little bit overwhelming like Fame could
be a little crazy normally everybody
think hey your life is dead what is mine
that was the last Instagram post card he
shared on Sunday before turning herself
into police I got these prison abraeve
I'm still be the next day cardi had no
braves in sight instead the rapper was
seen rocking a blonde wig white blouse
tan skirt and white heels as bodyguards
surrounded her shielding her face with
umbrellas exactly one month after the
alleged altercation she performed at the
2018 global citizen concert in Central
Park her first performance since giving
birth to daughter culture in July how
are you feeling in your pregnancy I feel
very happy I feel like I want to work at
food I don't know I feel very energetic
to keep on going like powerful like like
a woman
[Music]
[Applause]